what does it mean how you built wild now
into this franchise hey it's the age
season a while now and it's funny people
that why do you continue to do it is
it's a brand that is near and dear to my
heart I'm diversifying the business and
since I started off as a TV show but now
we're a digital component where a game
component we're opening wiling out
sports bars and comedy clubs across the
country tapping in with different sports
teams and stuff so just really taking
that brand that myself and Viacom bill
in you know allowing it to expand why
leave America's Got town it seems like a
dream job why leave that job because
it's a job I'm not defined by a job so
it wasn't an emotional decision not at
all everything I do is calculate how do
you and my work it out cuz it seems like
it's a really it is a very good
relationship that it comes from a place
of love respect and friendship at the
end of day we have nothing but respect
and admiration for that woman that woman
is a queen for more on Nick's exit from
a GT his love for his family and what's
next for his career to an end eet Friday
March 10
you